[موسيقى]
هل تشعر هذه ان الملفي يديها لم يعد يكفيك
السابق هذا هو التضخم باختصار في احد
تجليات ان تنخفض القدره الشرائيه للعملات
وان ترتفع تكلفه السلع والخدمه تقول منظمه
العمل الدوليه ان معدل التضخم خلال العام
الماضي تضعفت ثلاث مرات عن ما كان عليه في
عام 2021 كان الحرب الروسي على اوكرانيا
اثر كبير في ذلك مع توقف سلاسل الامداد
لكثير من السلع الاساسيه كذلك لم يتعافى
العالم بعد من تبعات جائعه كورونا
هذا الوضع انعكس بطبيعه الحال على شركات
التكنولوجيا العالميه وادي السيليكون
عنوان شركات التقنيه في العالم
يتدفق القلق في مكاتب عمان لقت
التكنولوجيا تكبدت هذه الشركات خسائره
فادحه خلال الاشهر الماضيه تفسير ذلك يعود
الى ان الطلب على خدمات هذه الشركات ارتفع
بشكل قياسي في فتره الجائحه الناس في
بيوتهم يستخدمون منصه التواصل ويحتاجون
لخدمات الكترونيه اكثر في تلك المرحله
كانت شركه امازون للشحن والتوصيل المنزلي
مثلا ترفعوا من عدد موظفها في المستودعات
بعد ان استعاد الناس حياتهم عاقبا انتهاء
الجائحه خفضت امازون عدد موظفيها وسرحت
اكثر من
18,000 منهم صحيح ان هؤلاء لا يمثلون نسبه
كبيره من عدد الموظف فيها الذي يصل الى
مليون ونصف المليون شخص الا ان العدد لا
يزال كبيرا اذا اضيف الى المسرحين من
الشركات الاخرى
تعلن جوجل تسريحات 12 الف موظف وكذلك فعلت
فيسبوك من قبل باستغناء عن اكثر من 11,000
بالاضافه الى قرار مايكروسوفت ايضا
بالتخلي عن اكثر من 10,000 وظيفه هنا يقول
الرئيس التنفيذي لمايكروسوفت انه رغم
ارتفاع انفاق مستهلك على منتجات الشركه
شهد هذا التوجه تحولا كبيرا الى توخي
الحذر قبل الشراء حضر الناس هذا في
العمليات الشرائيه هو الركود في مصطلحات
المختصين صحيح ان العالم لم يدخل مرحله
الركود بشكل رسمي لكن الانذارات ترتفع من
قربها
كده اصبح كثير هنا يتوخون الحذر قبل
الشراء او الانتفاع بالخدمات التقنيه ما
سحب عمالقه التكنولوجيا في العالم الى
مربع الاستغناء عن الموظفين ويرقبوا
العالم اشهرا قد تكون صعبه على الاقتصاد
وبالتالي جيوب النفس
[موسيقى]